[Music]
this is Devon
they called Devon a miracle child he
survived a rare birth defect that almost
cost him his life
in grade school he was bullied because
of a hearing impairment
[Music]
he used sports to express himself in
high school davonne only weighed 140
pounds but that didn't stop the kids got
heart
[Applause]
and this is Marshall Marshall was always
playing sports going up and loved to
ride a board or two in high school
Russia became a football star he would
be he was prone to do had an inner
feeling or Devon balled out at Central
High School in Baton Rouge but no one
offered him a scholarship instead he
walked on a Southern University where
his dad played
[Music]
Russia was Allstate in Florida had
colleges lining up so he chose judging
where more creeks and the dogs had an
opening kick after Keith he was
automatic
by seeing you Marshall was one of the
best kickers in the country and unlike
other kickers rushar didn't shy away
from contact Devon didn't start in
college it took every chance to prove
himself especially in the big games like
going up against Georgia in 2015 that's
when I met Devon and that's how I'm in
Washington
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I just seen this guy
[Music]
I heard the band playing I was thinking
I have to get up my team need me I have
to get up but nothing was budget so I
was just laying there
[Music]
southern flaire on the field in the
Georgia athletic training staff first
once there the near sideline to look
after exit saw the blow happened
his first one there as to what was going
on and he said he couldn't feel anything
or didn't move I couldn't I couldn't
move anything but my hands that's a
scary feeling collision on the return
right side your screen number 33 meets
up with number 13 collided at the end of
the play with the guy who's been the
best tackler on Georgia's kickoff
coverage to the kicker Marshall Morgan
once I started talking to the sideline I
look back and he's not getting up that's
when I started kind of freaking out
things are going through my mind like it
could have been this this what I hope he
moves like because I first he wasn't
moving at all
Devon gales sophomore from Baton Rouge
out of Central High School Mark Richt
has made his way over
scary moment yep
broadcaster came on and said that we
have Devon Gill Southern University wide
receiver number 33 down on the field of
course my heart dropped to see my son
laying there on that field helpless not
being able to get up it was it was
heartbreaking I felt the pain hurt
because I wasn't there and they're gonna
cart the young man off the field our
prayers go out that everything's okay
with Devon gales I was around 5/8 158 so
out pretty small but I was still being
in the heart it was a freak accident
I actually hit him
I see Devon she's running towards me and
so in my mind I'm thinking this guy's
coming to lay me out so I just tried to
get a good base and just kind of almost
absorb it I wasn't looking to lay anyone
out the way we collided it was this
tragic I mean right at the point of
impact Devon actually lowered his head
down and soared the blow and the problem
with that is when you lower your head
your spine becomes straight and his
source of force like a column so we knew
he had significant spotters at that
point I would just telling myself I'm
gonna be okay I'm gonna be okay but my
parents I lose they were worried about
me
[Music]
the doctors told me I was paralyzed
one side of me wanted to cry the other
side gym one stay strong for my family
he was able to move his hands he wasn't
able to move his fingers but at the same
time nothing he couldn't feel anything
from his chest all the way down to his
toes the doctor told us that there was a
50-50 chance that he could walk again I
had to get a metal rod the back of my
neck with screws I started here he could
be paralyzed I was like this is way too
serious like this can't be happening I'm
thinking you know his parents are gonna
hate me that everyone's gonna think I'm
I'm the guy that just just paralyzed the
Vong kind of thing right then I was like
I need to go see this kid and I need to
go see his parents and I felt like I'd
uh like apologize
the next day he was undergoing some
surgeries at the time I go to the
hospital and I kind of walk up and I see
his mom we wrapped our arms around each
other and just started crying I'm trying
to hold this big guy up and I'm like
okay baby you know it's okay you know I
just kinda had to comfort him and let
him know that we don't blame you for any
of this and I don't want you to blame
yourself some families it could have
been the totally opposite and they're
just the most loving and forgiving and I
mean what's welcoming family ever this
is just something that happens in
football well that's a heavy burden to
carry and as much as I could have spoken
to him in his ear I knew that he still
had that blame on himself you know he
had concern if you're in the middle of a
play like that you can't help but be
affected by it in some way it could have
gone either way
I wish it didn't happen either of us
yes yeah because of the Vaz injury the
Gaels family life actually changed just
like that
around my neck
[Music]
hey what smell my brick nope
here's a guy that's been through a rough
injury that you know him and his family
probably gonna need some help
financially and there's an opportunity
to do that
and I'm I'm calling all dogs to do that
coach Richt he said regardless of the
color of devons jersey right now he's
one of us or whatever you need he said
you have it bad news didn't have a spine
injury hospital and talk with everybody
we felt stronger this Shepherd was the
best facility for him in the nation to
go to we're forcing us right down the
street from the University of Georgia so
it was a nice fit
[Music]
I have my little moments every day I
just wish I'm up and doing something
like just to do you say dad I'm a walk
again
and I gotta believe it I can't help
daughter my child and and not me and my
wife believe that he will I miss
football a lot I had one day not like
man I wish I'd I wouldn't hit Marshall
but you can't redo what's been done
[Music]
after Devon was injured I would always
talk to Marshall just to check on him
because I know once you're involved in
the situation we heard someone is gonna
go through your mind you could tell that
it weighed on him a little bit all the
stuff that was going on in my mind I was
still thinking about Devon as I ride the
season out I'm getting updates about
Devon recovery every time I get an
update it's more positive there's just a
big motivator like I was playing for him
I wanted to make him proud
George Allegiant
[Applause]
you know he really wanted to get a
chance to meet Devon face-to-face and
you know it's Justin ended his talk to
him we decided to invite Devon his
family down to one of our football games
that was the first time I met washing
impression
[Music]
giggling in real life isn't that your
phone
that's when to kill the blame kind of
just switch from there I was always
trying reach out to him and you do the
same he wished me good luck before games
it was just nice to be able to talk to
him that's really what started this
relationship and you just hit it off
from there he wanted to be there with me
to his journey because it's not just
mine as he is too
[Music]
he's strong as now I don't know if I'd
be able to be as positive as he is him
going through one of the toughest things
that a human could go through
[Music]
a lot of times people visit but then as
time goes on you know they sort of drift
away but Marshall will kept in touch
with the family and they developed a
strong friendship when something happens
then that magnitude you you tend to get
to know people a little bit more because
you're living through the pain and the
corporal victory in the end and I just
like hanging around him hanging out with
them
he's just inspiration
I'm here for you you're here for me just
like a normal brother would do for your
liver they bonded with this injury it's
something that we may not understand but
it's something between the two of them
[Music]
other than my wife's family you know my
first invites Madison nas wedding was
Devon
[Music]
they're meant a lot to me
[Music]
and washa was like can i push the bunny
and I'm like dude you're getting married
you're supposed to be standing there
waiting to walk in oh no no I want to do
this myself I got to push him down and
you know let people kind of just see how
he is family I felt a part of the family
I am part of the family
[Music]
I posted a video of devons first time
being in a set of robotic legs
davonne always said he will walk again I
said even if it's not on his own just
yet this is just a small stepping-stone
when it first happened that's kind of
what I was praying for it to see that he
couldn't move it all much at first and
to see him like that
that's unbelievable I totally believe
I'm gonna walk again in time better than
I welcome before
[Music]
davonne kinda made me realize that you
know there's more to life than football
really it's about relationships he is
the most positive inspirational person
I've ever met
I'm grateful that I was able to have a
bond with him
fate brought us together b-but another
life until my future
it made us brothers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]